so eight years off right from doing like
films and stuff like so why that I I
appreciate that cuz even in the music
world it's nice to have a break I didn't
try I just I basically just been hanging
around I mean yeah like talking talking
to my friends raising my kids like
decorating that's the important thing
too though yeah and then during coid the
script came to me and I was like oh I've
always wanted to write I've always
wanted to write a screenplay so that's
what happened it it's you know it's a
movie basically they're locked down in
the movie together and we were locked
down at the time yeah and had all this
time to uh to write what a perfect movie
to do in the lockdown time it's really
y'all yeah well I mean I think I think
you probably thought well you didn't
know how long the lockdown was going to
last so it was a movie that you could
have actually shot during the pandemic
that's what I mean yeah there's just two
of us that's it that's all except for
all the people that were actually in the
airport except for the yes the extras
but we're the only ones who talk they're
not extras no these were it was a
working airport you know there were
actual people they were real people are
you serious in fact I I recognize some
of them
um so I have to say you're both in
romcoms that are so massively popular
that people love and adore so I'm not
what you you are return to me is like
one of my favorite
what so wait what's your what's the best
time you feel to watch a romcom when do
you want like it's like sad music when
do you listen to when you when you're
when you're getting old being sick yes
that's what people tell me
anyway that is true yeah like when
you're recovering and you you feel like
you cracked it and you're on the upwing
you need something nice yes kind that's
when I watch Doris Day the yeah all
those old things exactly just you when
that's what I do I watch i w well I
watch a real well-known film called
return to
me and you've got me I watch all those
when you want to watch a romcom what do
you what mood are you in yeah what mood
I don't I don't know I think here's my
honest answer when I find one when I'm
flipping flipping it's either Good
Fellas and people going to kill each
other
I can go with that too I get into The
Equalizer whenever I'm like not feeling
good and I just want to kick someone's
ass yeah it's a good movie um well it's
not a romcom but
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home